this world is not yet ready
for all that you will do
you will become a legend
[Music]
welcome to your weekly ticket
oscar isaac is set to play solid snake
in the sony pictures film
metal gear solid the film will be based
on the 33 year old video game franchise
of the same name which was originally
created by the legendary hideo kojima
for konami
wherein solid snake searches for a
nuclear super weapon called metal gear
kong skull island director jordan volt
roberts will direct with a script by
derek connolly
peter dinklage has been tapped to lead a
toxic avenger reboot
the original cult classic from 1984
centered on a mild-mannered man named
melvin who becomes disfigured after
falling into a vat of toxic waste
and goes on to fight bad guys under the
superhero named
toxie the new film which will be in the
vein of deadpool will be directed by
make and blair and produced by tromas
lloyd kaufman and michael hurts
alongside mega producers legendary
entertainment
and with christmas aka the release of
wonder woman 1984 just around the corner
we now have an official runtime a fresh
teaser from comic-con sao paulo
and first reactions from critics who've
seen the film
the sequel to 2017's wonder woman will
run an epic
two hours and 31 minutes and the first
reactions to the dceu sequel sound
promising
caramel horn wrote had a chance to
screen wonder woman film last night
it's a nostalgic romp through diana's
lore with deep cuts for hardcore fans
but light enough for families to watch
with their kids over the holidays
geeks of color shared wonder woman 1984
is a superb sequel to its predecessor
it will make you laugh make you cry and
make you scream for more
pedro pascal and kristen wiig as max
lord and cheetah were amazing
kudos to patty jenkins and the team for
making another thrilling film
just wait until you see it and
fandango's very own eric davis said
i'm so happy to report that wonder woman
1984 is an
absolute blast from start to finish an
exceptional compliment to the first film
it's stuffed with heart hope love action
romance and humor
patty jenkins gal gadot and team
delivered one of dc's best
sequels i was in tears when it ended
as 2020 comes to a close and we approach
the holiday season we're celebrating by
taking a look at fandango now's list
of holiday romance films and there is no
one better to dive into this list of
romantic
holiday movies then film critic writer
and author of have yourself a movie
little christmas
alonzo duralday happy holidays alonzo
happy holidays good morning so you
literally
wrote the book on this so you have to
enlighten us
what ingredients make a great holiday
romance
i think when you're looking at christmas
movies overall um
there's a real sense of redemption
forgiveness you know it's the time when
families get together and maybe have
that conversation they haven't had
before or you know decide to
look past you know the things of the
past so i think that when you're looking
at holiday romance more often than not
it's about a couple who maybe
knew each other before maybe they were
they grew up together or they
they broke up and now this is getting a
second chance there's something
that that i think about a holiday
romance where you really want there to
be that feel of redemption that idea of
like
we messed this up before but this time
we're gonna get it right because of
christmas
right initially i was like oh you make
it sound like a pressure cooker
it's like the holidays really intensify
it but that's an unromantic way of
looking at it
okay it kind of amplifies emotion i
think is what it is that and i think
there's also the idea of you know at
christmas time maybe we can find
our best selves and the best versions of
other people and
that's who you want to fall in love with
that's that's a beautiful way of saying
it i love that
so who then is your favorite holiday
couple
i think really george and mary bailey
like they just they set the bar for
everybody else you know she's clearly
interested in
from a very early age it takes him a
while to come around and figure out
what's going on there but
there is such a palpable set like
they're a
sexy couple that scene where she's on
the phone with sam wainwright
and he's right there next to her and
they're just like
breathing on each other like that's for
a 40s movie that is
crazy hot and then later in the film he
has that really
hard to watch scene where he's just
flipping out and he's
he you know thinks he's going to go to
jail and he's lashing out at his family
and it's like that's a that's a lot to
bounce back from but then you get that
amazing ending where she's gone out and
rallied the town on his behalf and
he's you know had this other this look
at what you know pottersville would have
been and and and
really comes to understand everything in
his life that does work and
she's principal among those things and
so when they
when when he is just like devouring her
at the end when she comes running in the
house and
whips that scarf off her head and he
just can't get enough of her
like that's that's a that's a hot and
heavy christmas moment
oh that's great yeah do you watch that
one like routinely
on christmas or oh yeah yeah absolutely
i mean in in normal years here in los
angeles the the aero theater in santa
monica
screens it every year and usually on
like the 22nd 23rd
and that's been sort of an annual
tradition and we're going to have to
sort of like wing it with the blu-ray
this year but uh yeah going to see it's
a wonderful life uh when you have when
you can see it on the big screen
is totally like a part of my my annual
holiday tradition
man i'll have to i'll have to check that
out just zoom just zoom
movies this year pretty much yeah now
we can't talk about modern holiday
romance without getting into like the
massive catalog
of hallmark and lifetime movies so what
do you
what do you love about these movies and
do you have a favorite you know the the
hallmark lifetime movies
are i think in a lot of ways this great
sort of delivery system
for you know the kind of the things that
we want out of christmas in terms of
just like the visuals of nothing else
it's the tree lighting and it's the
cookie decorating and it's the
you know like let's go caroling and
let's have a snowball fight and build a
snowman and
you know it it is kind of a it's a
christmas card come to life you know and
and that's what that's where hallmark's
main business is so it makes sense that
that's what they would do
and then as far as their love stories go
i think very often the the the
one of the plot tropes they kind of keep
coming back to is the
oh we were high school sweethearts but
then you know she went to the big city
and he didn't or
you know or there's some kind of thing
in the past and it's tied into
our families are close together and so
uh you know that that
that amplifies the coziness of it all um
but they don't always have to be that
way in fact i'd say my favorite one
is a film that aired last year on
hallmark movies and mysteries
uh called two turtle doves and it's
about a woman who
comes back after her grandmother has
died and the grandmother raised her
uh she's inherited her house and the
grandmother has stipulated in the will
i want you to spend a christmas year i
want you to do all of our christmas
traditions and then you can decide after
that
do you want to commit to staying here is
this going to be part of your life or do
you want to just sell the house and move
on
uh living next door to her is the guy
who was the the grandmother's estate
attorney
and he's a widow so they both
experienced loss but they're both kind
of
working together and with his young
daughter to kind of make the holiday
magical for each other
um they're played by nikki delosh and
michael rady and they
have a crazy amount of chemistry and uh
you know there's a trope in the hallmark
movies you always see which is the
almost kiss
you know where they like they go in for
it and then like somebody's phone rings
or somebody interrupts every church
bells go off
yeah whatever it takes like they can't
because they can't kiss till the end you
know
that's changing there's some this year
but usually in hallmark they couldn't
kiss till the very end
and this one is really smart and then
she comes in for the kiss
twice and he's like i would love to kiss
you right now but until i know that
you're ready to really commit to being
here
and to like making a life with me and my
daughter i'm not going to
cross that line because it would be too
hard later to say goodbye to you and
it's like
oh wow human behavior you know we don't
get that all the time in hallmark and
lifetime movies but in this movie
they really land that moment so when
they do kiss at the end it really means
something
uh so yeah i think that's a really great
one it's a great love story if people
want to check that one out
awesome um my final question nightmare
before christmas
christmas movie or halloween movie yes
all right well thank you so much alonzo
where can people find you
uh i'm at a doraldi on twitter you can
read my reviews at thewrap.com
uh and i host a whole bunch of podcasts
including linoleum knife which just
celebrated its 10th anniversary that i
do with my husband dave white awesome
well happy holidays happy holidays and
please
if you haven't picked it up already have
yourself a movie little christmas it's a
great
holiday film guide and it'll give you
some fun ideas maybe for some
movies you've never checked out before
and uh you know will become part of your
annual tradition
dude and such a great book title
so good i thought it was like nice
all right see ya thanks much
available to watch at home on friday is
wild mountain time
it's not normal i don't care you take
after john kelly and that man was mad as
the full moon
drowned himself he fell in he had a rock
tied to his neck
headstrong farmer rosemary muldoon has
her heart set on winning her neighbor
anthony riley's love
the problem is anthony seems to have
inherited a family curse and remains
oblivious to his beautiful admirer
stung by his father's plans to sell the
family farm to his american nephew
anthony is jolted into pursuing his
dreams
the film stars emily blunt jamie dornan
christopher walken and jon hamm
also available to watch at home on
friday is songbird
tensions rise as we enter the 213th week
of lockdown grim new reality emerges
23 has mutated songbird is set in 2024
where kobit 23 has mutated to the point
that the world is in its fourth year of
lockdown
and infected americans are forced from
their homes and into quarantine camps
the film follows a handful of people as
they navigate the obstacles currently
hindering society
disease martial law quarantine and
vigilantes
the thriller is produced by michael bay
and stars kj appa
sophia carson craig robinson demi moore
and alexandra d'addario
alright well that's it for today but
leave us a comment and let us know who
your favorite holiday couple is
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
[Music]